this is a sickness
of the highest order eh
um
don't worry if you're looking at the
title and you think that I'm quitting or
preaches quitting uh
um
there's late uh
take three ah what let's just go
um
take four
I just wanted
to do a quick little video I want to
preach is on vacation
to talk about how much I hate that no
I won't talk
I want to say thank you okay you the
viewer watching right now you're looking
at the screen or maybe you're just
hearing me because when you watch your
videos you never pay attention to the
screen I know there's some of you like
that
um but stuff you can hear me thank you
um this YouTube career in a lot of ways
has been life-changing a lot of ways it
hasn't
thanks to you guys
a lot of aspects of my life have changed
not necessarily for me personally but
for the people around me and when I see
those blessings being extended to other
folks and see them doing well feeling
well I'm reminded that this is possible
in large part because you viewers are so
supportive you guys tune in all the time
I see some of you guys that said like
you're the most watched Channel and all
this stuff and it's very heartwarming
even though I have a hard time
expressing gratitude sometimes even when
we hit a million subscribers a lot of
people like
where's the celebration I I struggle
with that sometimes
because I'll be honestly none of this
feels really real to me
um
success or even being kind of well known
of it really
feels real like all the paychecks and
all this stuff I'm always thinking I
don't know maybe it's because I'm
[ __ ] up but I always think that the
floor is going to come out at any point
it's going to be gone and so I don't
spend the money you know I don't uh I
don't uh I don't indulge I don't go
around me like I'm dead you know I just
I can't because I feel like it's just
it's gonna go away at any point it's why
you know this floor that you hear
little known fact this is actually my
apartment this is where I've lived over
the last eight years I don't plan on
moving out anytime soon I still have the
same roommate from this whole eight
years period you know I still go to the
same Metro like everything in my life is
still the same even though the
circumstances around have changed so
much
um but I'm grateful I'm so grateful
because thanks to you guys I've been
able to support a lot of organizations
initiatives to help me out when I was
starting out people who'd extended a
helping hand to me when I had nothing
and so I get to help them
um I get to help my mom retire early and
move her closer so you know as she gets
older I get to be there for her and
that's um that's a luxury you know
that's uh that's a luxury not everyone's
gonna have that kind of privilege to be
able to do that and
you guys supporting me helped me afford
that possibility you know
because uh my mom's worked hard she's
taking a lot of time out of her life to
take care of her kids and so just to be
able to be like yo let me let me carry
this load you know what I'm saying chill
out go take a breather go take a walk
you ain't got to stress about the bill
at the end of the day because I know
what it's like when you're you know
struggling and um yeah just thank you
you know
who want to come into this New Year
showing a bit of gratitude
um
to a lot of folks who probably deserve
it and who I haven't gone out of the way
to do it enough and I was thinking that
you viewers even though we'd be like
you're not part of you guys have
definitely influenced my life in ways um
you'll never know
and I'm really grateful you know so
yeah I just wanted to put together this
little video saying that
um I mean I'm still the same person
yeah if you catch me in the streets come
say what's up you know what I'm saying
don't yell don't scream because like I
feel super self-conscious when people
notice me but you just be like yo what's
up I'd love to say hi to each and every
single one of you yeah so
um I just want to say that and
thank you thank you so [ __ ] much
you guys have changed my life and uh
changed the lives of the people around
me so
I owe you guys maybe not a drink because
there's like two million of you but I
mean you know if you catch me what I
want maybe maybe I can get you like a
dessert you know what I'm saying
uh this is embarrassing but
you know
it is what it is so
I want you guys to know this is this is
not his sickness
this is an antidote see we are going to
enjoy this year we are going to try to
make it better than the last
there's going to be a great deal of Dr
Martin semper on this channel
today we are going to take a bit of time
huh to say a few words to you the viewer
if you are watching right now I see you
huh I know you're in the comments I know
some of you are not in the comments
either some of you are not even watching
you are listening because you don't want
to see your face the whole time you want
to go do other things while you listen
to us in the background put me in the
foreground right now look at this look
at the phone look at the screen eh and I
want to say something to you watching eh
thank you
I am grateful you have influenced my
life in a positive way
my friend is a papaya
had that Bishop look at these ones they
have come into my life they have given
me many blessings
no
it's been a good night you wonder why
I'm sweating it's because I was
I was just dancing so don't be getting
no [ __ ] dirty ideas you little nasty
ass